à l'ehess que l'hygiène compte pour ne
pas attraper le coronavirus parce que
comme je l'annoncé c'est vrai que vous
avez une petite révélation à nous faire
sur le corona virus est ce que voilà si
on est propre si on se lave souvent les
mains si on se lave beaucoup est-ce
qu'on a moins de chances d'attraper le
virus
c'est très important parce que le
coronavirus on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
ah ouais merde c'est je le répète il
n'ya pas d'accès n'y a pas de traitement
donc les règles d'hygiène et y en a
énormément son sexe dans ce livre j'ai
alors si toi les règles parce que là
pour les gens qui nous regardent et
après vous nous donnerez gg j'ai entendu
dire un truc je vous pose la question
parce que si c'est ça c'est c'est chaud
mais dites moi juste les les règles
voilà qu'il faut respecter
d'abord c'est vrai que le virus peut
rester quelques heures et des allemands
découvert qui peut rester jusqu'à neuf
jours actifs sûrs alors c'est ça qui
c'était ça le scoop plus rien à dire que
le virus il peut acheter les allemands
ont découvert aujourd'hui le virus
pouvait rester neuf jours actifs et je
vois la sueur même sur des ouï à l'air
libre
donc tous les produits qui sont
importées par exemple voilà et qui
peuvent être infectés du coronavirus
pendant neuf heures ils seront affectés
au jour le jour
à neuf jours du canot on avait dit que
quelques heures
à neuf jours c'est ce que les allemands
découvrent les produits ah oui ou qui
sont apportées peut-être voilà deux
régions où il ya le coronavirus et ben
ça veut dire qu'ils sont affectés par
les coronavirus ça veut dire qu'il faut
prendre les nouveaux réflexes par
exemple sa frappe en postillonnant mais
aussi si on met à sa bouche une zone
contaminée
ah ouais donc penser à bien se laver les
mains ayez une technique faut bien se
laver les mains avec soin les espaces
c'est chez grasset chaque fois que c'est
possible mais aussi éviter serré aussi
la main des gens en vrai et puis c'est
beaucoup mieux
harry coup de bol ça va plus vite mais
dr des germes et bien je suis le médecin
je fais est un journal en attendant
atterrissent à bala c'est pas ta
coronavirus talent qui fut simplement
une personne n'est deux fois par an les
mains à la bouche
non non vous pouvez avoir des airs fois
par jour par heure au visage ou la
bouche de poids par or donc en fait
c'est très important de nettoyer ce soit
son portable et carte de crédit tout ce
qu'on peut aller danse le plus d'hygiène
possible et comme je disais même avant
de se mettre les doigts dans le nez il
faut nettoyer ses mains
parce que sinon des virus peuvent se
mettre alors la complète la muqueuse
nasale
non mais alors et donc quels sont les
risques sont maintenant on dit voilà il
ya des colis on va voir une vidéo
on a une vidéo vrai au début de
l'épidémie dont on disait qu'il n'y
avait aucun risque avec les colis venant
de chine notamment et regardez c'était
dans tous les journaux et maintenant
vous nous dites que c'est faux dr shaman
on va regarder on en parle de ça pour
regarder ils s'inquiètent dans toutes
les langues pour leurs produits
commandés sur alibaba ou sur wish une
des internautes nous a même poser
directement la question sur lci.fr
regardez y at il un gros risque en
recevant des colis de ramener le virus
en france
les médecins sont très clairs la
transmission du coronavirus se fait
d'humain à humain
quand bien même un objet serait infectée
il faut prendre en compte la dégradation
du virus voilà qui réagit ce qu'ils
disent enfin maintenant on nous dit que
mine de rien les colis peuvent être
infectés alors le virus oui se dégradent
effectivement tout de suite dans les
heures qui suivent
il y en a pas mal et peu sûre vieux
petit à petit l'ibpt est beaucoup moins
activement mais c'est également
découvert que j'étais d'ailleurs moi
même très surpris que je neuf jours plus
tard il avait toujours mais en quantité
moindre donc quelque part si vous
recevez un colis ah ouais rien n'empêche
nettoyer ces deux chercheurs allemands
j'ai pris mes 100 black & decker vous
souvenez à haut début les pauvres
employés de d'entreprise qui recevait
des colis de la première région affectée
en chine on les ridiculise est là sur
idée m est ce qu'on doit être inquiet
mais pas du tout et n'importe quoi en
fait ces gens là avaient raison de
s'inquiéter
c'est ça qui est fou dr y avoir encore
s'abaisse énormément mais j'avoue que
cette découverte des allemands ni manger
représente cette découverte fait peur
quand même à une réalité rue souris sont
contagieux ils ont la peau dure
ah oui on a dit aussi excusez moi qu'on
avait découvert peut-être un traitement
anti paludisme qui serait efficace sur
le coronavirus qu'est-ce qu'on l'instant
on n'a pas de traitement
il ya des hypothèses mais c'est en train
de changer on cherche c'est pas évident
du tout parce que même le temps de
mettre un vaccin au point ça prend du
temps
mais on l'a pas en vue là d'accord donc
alors les règles comme vous ne l'avez
dire avec vos d'hygiène juste d'une
question que j'ai déjà posé hier un
autre médecin le coronavirus mine de
rien est ce que c est ce qu'on peut
avoir le coronavirus est-ce qu'on peut
ne pas s'en rendre compte
parce que voilà c'est pas on n'a pas
d'aidé symptômes trop trop de route
voilà qui nous pénalisent mouly et fort
heureusement parce que ça peut
ressembler à un vague rumeur rien du
tout beaucoup de gens peuvent la voir il
va pas se passer grand chose et il ya
des gens qui disent que on a lu une
étude 40 à 70% de la population qui va
être touchée par le coroner et vous mais
ensuite ce qui va compter c'est quoi
c'est l'immunité
ouais donc en fait si on a un bon
système immunitaire y réagit bien c'est
pour ça que j'ai insisté sur le fait de
tout ce qui peut augmenter notre
immunité fait du bien que ce soit
l'exercice physique quotidien quand on
fait une demi-heure d'exercice physique
par jour on est immunisé qui monte et je
veux dire ça ça vaut la peine
si par exemple tiens pour la grippe ont
découvert que les gens qui dorment moins
de sept heures par nuit aux deux fois
plus de risques d'attraper la grippe ou
des virus y arriver de weleda trapattoni
ça c'est sûr donc de la qualité du
sommeil
et puis plus récemment j'en parle dans
le livre le jeune séquentielle ou un
nobel japonais a découvert que quand les
gens pratiquent ce type de jeunes ils
ont une immunité plus fort donc en fait
c'est très intéressant et je pense que
ras un avant et un après gros navires us
parce que c'est quelque part réalisant
dès mailles gêne pour mieux se protéger
et tout faire pour avoir une immunité
pour passer au travers
ok allez je vous laisse je dois aller au
bloc c'était docteur anna merci
[Applaudissements]